[Music]
in doctor in the new house news doctor
in the house
submitted by Cindy from Tampa Florida Oh
talk about Kim Jong stopped his stand-up
set to provide medical attention to an
audience member or her about this he's a
legit doctor yeah yeah that's wild
so he was like knock-knock oh [ __ ] any
[ __ ] went out there like knock knock
who's there a coronary corner
mrs. Kim Jong I'm just in case you guys
didn't know he won so he is a real-life
MD he does still have a license to
practice in the state of California all
right so go take a woman a little bit
there like a nice woman yeah a woman
that's real friendly can I see the
picture of them again doesn't he
looks like I feel a Filipino lady
actually then I know he really does look
like a nice lady yeah it's so he was in
Phoenix Arizona and that's when it's so
true yeah happy he does you might have
flash shattering bovid right down stand
up and that's when a woman started
seizing having a notion that what is
called a seizing
no cuz we couldn't cuz our dog had
seizures and my coming season she's
gonna season they were like oh bring it
straight season again did she still get
the pills yeah no pills every day no way
is it hard to get a pill at all nah
she's she loves it as soon as she hears
a little container with medicine cup she
like rockets up the smoke yeah not a
dog's own stuff they know stuff their
own stuff oh yeah yeah yeah my little
Sophie's on a stomach acid medicine yep
Zala tall my grandfather was on xylitol
like [ __ ] it acid reflux [ __ ] yeah yeah
what else from Memphis all or some [ __ ]
yeah her hip is a new truck I know she's
got makeup noisy a drug permit ah yeah I
used to play about Japanese buddies I
would like make a sound and see if it
was a word I don't talk about my mother
that lady are you my mom that's crazy
they had to do to my show on time he was
laughing came out of the closet with his
buddies I came out of his buddy this is
in Westwood it's like seven years ago
yeah yeah doing jokes yeah but I think
things can like happen that like makes
you like actus you know like you hit an
emotion dude yeah he couldn't hold it
after his buddies had bought him another
drink and everybody just kept it
hush-hush
yeah they're like whirl gay bro we know
you think you just hang out with a bunch
of dudes for no but that's Wow that he
was able to do that huh yeah so he so
she started having a seizure so he
initially thought it was a heckler and
so he doing oh my [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] foaming at the mouth is [ __ ] yeah
I'm so like audience members around they
were like no she really needs help and
then so finally like oh she's your
biggest fan he's like yes so then she
finally or he finally gets off the stage
and he starts assisting her and that's
when another audience member there was
an EMT so he was helping too and so he
stayed with the woman until the
paramedics took her away to the hospital
then he went back up and finished his
set what how do you do that that's
amazing is it
life was at a stand-up live-ins Phoenix
yeah no joke kid you not I was
performing there one time and a woman
had a seizure in the back and they had
to have they quietly came in the back
and took her out if that's not her job
during the whole show maybe the same
lady yeah well she's one of those crisis
actors yeah every single day is like ah
she's cashing those checks you know
alright she's like a plant audience we
get the app she's like all right we need
a seizure over on Rossdale Boulevard but
that's crazy
same spot yeah yeah that's where it was
now I can make the Jimmy I don't know I
didn't see her I think she was so far in
the back but I wonder if there's
something the lights are that's making
that happen to people does that seems
maybe you guys are just so [ __ ] funny
is I just making them see that you may
come cease to it was- a shuttle thing
but I'm assuming it's her someone so an
audience member tweeted out this photo
and the story so I don't know at least
draw an arrow I know it helped us out
they just show us a [ __ ] picture of
Pershing Square friends and family is
gonna be worried and [ __ ] like damn I
heard about the seizure like what it
could be anyone in that photo we don't
know even the men even like nobody's
really said to her either so you can't
tell we had increased the contrast more
people in the back cuz that sweet or the
photo that was a lazy [ __ ]
somebody died it ever there's some rare
to be able to stand out of the nightclub
bizarre yes we said Kim Jong at then
apply the woman had a medical emergency
during the show Ken thanks it's heckling
when people are asking for his help he
jumps off stage to assist an EMT helped
to then on with the show great night he
is gracious and grateful and flipping
funny well least we know he's a real
doctor for him I don't know what the
[ __ ] I do if I see so I'll be like
somebody help her I know
I've seen it happen in front of me and
you put it like something so that they
don't bite or swallow their tongue Oh
like this right yeah the woman that
tweeted out that consumer is her so she
was not the one oh you pointed her out
I'm sorry who do you care who did you're
picking this that hit her on the front I
think it's like girl in the back with
her husband I assume is that yeah she
tweeted it yeah I think it's not growing
the last show these things about the
Seas right there yeah hey yeah I think
I've been the one the far left you see
that it's a good one got those Seas eyes
yeah I agree
even know and I see British I've seen
her seas like three or four times is oh
honey okay no it's pretty [ __ ] funny
thought this dude he's like a huge like
Dodgers fan too so this year this was
going quick he goes ham at sports events
dude who is he like especially at like
like college like basketball football
games like he's like the icon there
that's awesome but I saw a clip of him
like roasting an audience member - that
smells kind of cracking up so it's like
you probably would hit on her ass before
she found I'm sure bro can you imagine
you go shut the [ __ ] up
oh sure oh [ __ ] we want this just shut
up for one thing is like giving her CPR
[ __ ] yeah wake up wake up dammit well
just seasoned died already super
inappropriate anything well she didn't
die she suffocated the [ __ ] cares
yeah she's maybe okay oh please she's
fine trust me she probably yeah I mean
she's gonna die one day I had a friend
who had a epilepsy and this fool it's
funny to me now yeah but this dude it I
guess like he's like seizures what he
gets nervous so he put it for a job
interview
haha he shook the guy's head imagine was
the first time having sex was like oh
you must have felt good for the girl yes
he's all vibrating like a [ __ ]
she's at all
ah that's her story
I've ever been [ __ ] was with a guy
just easier with his dick inside me and
he's too busy season to come so he's
just like yeah she's like that's our
[ __ ] tinder profile you have to have
epilepsy I know she's gonna blink a
flash when you're season though you're
also [ __ ] at the scene oh come on so
she double peep keep a hard-on why your
season I could do that's a new rodeo
human rodeo yeah see if you got to do
now is for a girl to find it do with
epilepsy and just break some glow sticks
and start raving in front of them to see
what happens you're going to hell if you
believe in hell bro I probably don't
believe in it yo you owe the youth
minister for two years don't let anybody
be there for real you yeah for real
youth only two years done it didn't work
out if you had jokes like that I think I
would have stayed devoted to
Christianity
no after I left that church all the kids
left they were like mad upset they
probably always a therapy I bet dude
that's crazy were a youth minister a
father's a pastor Wow
so I thought that my calling was all
supposed to be into ministry because you
know I just I just like talking to
people it turns out you just PS that it
could be him sensation but this is like
less restrictions yeah and so like I
thought it was my thing and then I
remember the day I figured out it wasn't
for me because I wanted to [ __ ]
murder all these kids who they're
pissing me off
because I wasn't even for them anymore
it was like you know like you have like
counsel to they're like you have to
learn how to be patient and you want to
do is tell them shut the [ __ ] up yeah
and I'm just sitting in with these kids
that are just all these rich kids and
they're telling me they're like rich kid
problems like they they're like selling
like robbing their cousin's house so
they could get oxycotin the [ __ ] I'm
like these aren't real problem you know
I mean and they're complaining to me
about their lives and then the long
story short just the last day was like I
lose out there and this kid was just
yapping off he thought he was funny I
looked at him I was like hey shut the
[ __ ] up and
I'm not a pastor I can't do this it's up
I really do my life I was like I can't
do this like this is not my college if I
could tell you to shut the [ __ ] up
in God's house yeah not my thing yeah
you go to a counselor for help and then
they tell you shut the [ __ ] up
can you imagine he was a troublemaker
too and so like I had to deal with him a
lot and then like his parents I actually
like chastise his parents cuz they were
like well what can we do it I was like
you're I looked at Mosley to be honest
with you if you want my honest opinion I
was like your terrible parents like you
give them money you give him a credit
card you let me spend whatever and then
you wonder why he's getting all these
drugs you're the [ __ ] reason and I
have to deal with him every [ __ ] day
and so like it got to that point where I
took his parents aside and I was like
the apparent - reel to reel stop
throwing money in their [ __ ] face and
be a [ __ ] adult be a parent or every
day he's gonna come here and I'm just
gonna destroy him every day and I'm
gonna break him down and eventually I
did ikaw he cleaned up that seems like
the Biggest Loser but for Christian
seems like a little bit he was like I
know the kid was [ __ ] delusion oh
that's an amazing show a good show it's
like scared straight but for Christians
yeah yeah it is so weird cuz you have to
balance out who can like take take the
heat you would be the best counselor on
it - that's why I will only be good
because you would be able to be like you
don't have the Lord in you you know and
you send them home what I'm on a scale
and it's like how much Lord they have
enemy oh there's a Lord scale the Lord
steel and then Lord the artists behind
them
[Laughter]
[Music]